absolutamente y por eso el abrigo es la
principal preocupación la gente no puede
quedarse en las calles con este es
temperaturas tan negativas además de ir
de eso hay cortes de Electricidad y
también de abastecimiento de agua y
entonces tenemos que garantizar el
calentamiento de las personas que están
desplazadas pero también la posibilidad
de que haya comida caliente distribuida
a las personas y además de eso ropas
calientes Porque mucha gente estaba
durmiendo y han sido recuperados o han
salido de sus casas con jopas mínimas y
hay necesidad de les dar ropas más
calientes y finalmente muy importante es
necesario proveer al acceso a
medicamentos a medicinas Porque mucha
gente tiene enfermedades que tienen
necesidad de apoyos médicos y los
hospitales están como
muy sobrecargados por las víctimas los
miles de heridos de heridos por El terre